PRESIDENT REITERATED THAT HIS
AMERICA FIRST MOVEMENT IS ONLY
JUST BEGUN.
MAKE NO MISTAKE.
AT LEAST 75 MILLION AMERICANS
WHO VOTED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP,
THEY ARE NOT GOING AWAY.
I’M ONE OF THEM, I’M NOT GOING
AWAY EITHER, ALTHOUGH MANY ON
THE LEFT WOULD PROBABLY LOVE
THAT.
OUR CONSERVATIVE VALUES, THEY
ARE NOT GOING AWAY.
OUR DEDICATION TO THE
CONSTITUTION, THAT’S NOT GOING
AWAY.
OUR LOVE OF FREEDOM AND JUSTICE
FOR ALL, THAT’S NOT GOING AWAY
EITHER.
LOOK AT THIS CROWD WHEN HE
ARRIVED IN FLORIDA.
WE WILL SHOW YOU MORE OF IT
COMING UP LATER, AND ALSO WE ARE
FOLLOWING THE STORY OUT OF
PORTLAND AND SEATTLE.
WE DON’T HAVE THE VIDEO YET.
COMING UP, WE WILL TALK ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF THE AMERICA FIRST,
MAKE AMERICA GREAT CONSERVATISM
AND THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
IT LIKE IT OR NOT, DEMOCRATS ARE
NOW IN CONTROL OF ALL BRANCHES O
GOVERNMENT, AND TO THE
WHITE HOUSE THIS MORNING,
JOE BIDEN WAS SWORN IN AS THE 46
PRESTON OF THE UNITED STATES.
JOE PREDICTABLY MEANDERED HIS
WAY THROUGH EDDIE TRULY
UNREMARKABLE, TOTALLY
FORGETTABLE REMARKS.
IF THEY WERE FLAT OUT LYING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS USUAL.
THIS IS NOT IN ANY WAY, SHAPE,
OR FORM A MEMORABLE SPEECH.
IT IT WILL NOT BE TALKED ABOUT
DECADES TO COME BARED IT TO BE
BLUNT, IT’S ALREADY FORGOTTEN.
EVEN BILL CLINTON SEEMED TO BE
FALLING -- HE’S NODDING OFF
THERE, FALLING ASLEEP.
A BERNIE SANDERS, HE LOOKED
MISERABLE.
I DON’T KNOW, LOOKED LIKE HE
THOUGHT HE WAS IN VERMONT.
AS I SAT ON THE RADIO THIS
AFTERNOON, THE INAUGURAL ADDRESS
SOUNDED LIKE AN UNINSPIRED
STUDENT COUNCIL PRESIDENT
ACCEPTANCE SPEECH FROM A GUY WHO
DESPERATELY WAS CREATING A NAP.
OF COURSE, THE MAIN THEME OF THE
SPEECH WAS UNITY.
AFTER FOUR YEARS OF OUTRIGHT
LYING, CONSPIRACY THEORIES,
WITCH HUNTS, ONE HOAX AFTER THE
OTHER, VITRIOL, NONSTOP
HYSTERIA, TO IMPEACHMENTS --
INCLUDING ONE THAT IS STILL
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY ONGOING AIR
TO BIDEN’S HOLLOW CALLS FOR
UNITY ARE BOTH LAUGHABLE AND
COMPLETELY DISINGENUOUS.
TOTAL AND COMPLETE B.S.
BUMPER STICKERS AND OLD WORN OUT
LIBERAL SOCIALIST CLICHES.
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> TO RESTORE THE SOUL AND
PROTECT THE FUTURE OF AMERICA
REQUIRE SO MUCH MORE THAN WORDS.
IT REQUIRES THE MOST ELUSIVE OF
ALL THINGS IN A DEMOCRACY, UNITY
UNITY.
>> THIS IS A BUNCH OF SCUMBAGS.
IF THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE.
THERE ARE VERY STRONG WORDS.
>> MY WHOLE SOUL IS IN THIS,
BRINGING AMERICA TOGETHER,
UNITING OUR PEOPLE, UNITING OUR
NATION.
>> YOU CANNOT BE CIVIL WITH THE
POLITICAL PARTY THAT WANTS TO
DESTROY WHAT YOU STAND FOR, WHAT
YOU CARE ABOUT.
>> WITH UNITY, WE CAN DO GREAT
THINGS ON THE IMPORTANT THINGS.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS A RACIST AND
HE IS A DEMAGOGUE.
THAT IS JUST A FACT.
>> FOR NOW, UNITY THERE IS NO
PEACE, ONLY BITTERNESS AND FURY.
TO SPEAK OF THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS BEHAVING LIKE A BUNCH OF
THUGS AND GANGSTERS.
>> WE MUST END THIS UNCIVIL WAR.
>> AND ARE HONORING OUR
CONSTITUTION ARE RIGHT AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE WITH
THEIR ALLIES IN THE CONGRESS OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WE CAN DO THIS.
IF WE OPEN OUR SOULS INSTEAD OF
PARDONING OUR HEARTS.
>> THE QUESTION IS, HOW ARE WE
GOING TO DEPROGRAM THESE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SIGNED UP FOR THE CULT
OF TRUMP?
BE WHEN YOU NEED TO BE
DEPROGRAMMED, YOU ARE IN A CULT
OF TRUMP.
SEND THEM TO PBS TORTURE CAMP
FOR EVERY DAY 24 HOURS A DAY
AFTER THEY TAKE YOUR KIDS AWAY
FROM YOU.
IF BIDEN TRULY WANTED UNITY
INSTEAD OF WORDS AND CLICHES, HE
WOULD’VE STARTED BY ENDING THE
VITRIOL IN HIS OWN PARTY.
FOR EXAMPLE, HE COULD HAVE
STOPPED COMPARING REPUBLICANS TO
LIKE HE DID A WEEK AGO.
HE COULD ASK HIS COLLEAGUES TO
STOP REFERRING TO 75 MILLION
PEACE-LOVING TRUMP SUPPORTER’S
AS DOMESTIC TERRORISTS THAT
SUPPORT INSURRECTION WHEN THEY
ABSOLUTELY DO NOT.
IF HE COULD CALL FOR AN END TO T
THE UNCONSTITUTIONALLY
POST-PRESIDENTIAL IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE.
HE COULD ALSO APOLOGIZE FOR THE
RUSSIA HOAX AND ALL OF THOSE
LIES, AND THE UKRAINIAN
IMPEACHMENT.
MARK MY WORDS, THIS WILL NEVER
HAPPEN.
BIDEN AND HIS RADICALS IN POWER
AND HIS PARTY, THEY DON’T GIVE A
RIP ABOUT UNITY.
SLOGANS, BUMPER STICKERS, FLAT
OUT LIES, AND SMEARS CONTINUE.
IF THAT DOESN’T MATTER TO THE
MOB AND MEDIA EITHER.
BY THE WAY, FOX NEWS ALERT
GRATIS STARTING AT 12:00 NOON
TODAY, 99 PLUS PERCENT OF THE
MEDIA MOB IN THIS COUNTRY AND
OFFICIALLY STARTED WHAT WILL BE
PRETTY MUCH A FOUR YEARS LONG
VACATION.
AT THE HARD-HITTING QUESTIONS
WILL BE GONE, THE COMBATIVE
PRESS CONFERENCES OVER, THAT WIL
BE A THING OF THE PAST.
AT THE TINGLING SENSATION UP AND
DOWN THE MEDIA MOB’S LEGS, THEY
ARE THROBBING LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
AFTER FOUR YEARS WITHOUT OBAMA
-GASMS THERE BACK TODAY, TONIGHT
TONIGHT.
TWEETING, BIDEN LANDING AT JOINT
BASE ANDREWS TONIGHT, I HAVE
CHILLS.
AT THE CHILLS ARE BACK, THE
THRILLS ARE BACK.
OVER THERE AT PROPAGANDA NETWORK
CONSPIRACY CHANNEL, ALL THINGS
LEFTIST, SOCIALIST, THEIR
CONTRIBUTOR COMPARED BIDEN TO
GOD THE FATHER ALMIGHTY.
A FAR LEFT WANNABE COMEDIAN
JIMMY KIMMEL TWEETING, CONGRATS
TO OUR NEW PRESIDENT.
WE KNOW YOU WILL DO YOUR BEST TO
MAKE AMERICA GOOD AGAIN.
I WONDER IF HE’S GOING TO ATTACK
JILL BIDEN THE WAY HE DID
MELANIA TRUMP.
OPRAH WINFREY COMPLAINING THAT C
AND PASSION HAVE BEEN RESTORED
BUT HALLELUJAH HE APPEARED TO DO
THEY EVER WATCH ANY REAL NEWS?
APPARENTLY NOT.
THEY ARE CLUELESS OF THE REALITY
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
REDDICK OF THE LEFT HAS BEEN
PAID AND MAKE NO MISTAKE, THE
THRILLS AND CHILLS ARE
OFFICIALLY BACK TONIGHT IN THE U
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> LIGHTS ARE SHOOTING OUT FROM
THE LINCOLN MEMORIAL ALONG THE
REFLECTING POOL.
THE EXTENSIONS OF JOE BIDEN’S
ARMS EMBRACING AMERICA.
IT WAS A MOMENT WHERE THE NEW
PRESIDENT CAME TO TOWN AND
CONVENED THE COUNTRY AND A
MOMENT OF REMEMBRANCE OUT
STRETCHING HIS ARMS.
>> PRESIDENT-ELECT JOE BIDEN AND
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS PULLED THE
GRIEF AND REGRET OUT OF THE
PRIVACY OF OUR HEARTS.
IF JUST FOR A MOMENT, SO WE ALL
COULD SHARE IT.
WHAT A BEAUTIFUL STEP.
I’M REMINDED OF -- HE HEALS THE
BROKENHEARTED AND BINDS UP THEIR
WOUNDS.
>> WHAT A STORY, WHAT A GREAT
LOVE STORY BETWEEN JILL AND TO
JOE BIDEN, THE WAY SHE HELPED
HIS FAMILY RECOVER FROM TRAGEDY
TO BRING JOE BACK FROM WHAT HE’D
LOST, IT’S A WONDERFUL STORY.
WE HAVEN’T HAD A LOVE STORY IN
THE WHITE HOUSE IN FOUR YEARS.
>> WE NEEDED THIS.
THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
BEAUTY HEALS.
THERE WAS NOT ONE PART OF THAT
THAT WASN’T JUST MEDICINE IN THE
WOUND.
>> HE IS THE BETTER ANGEL
PRESIDENT.
IT JOE BIDEN BELIEVES HE’S
ETERNALLY OPTIMISTIC.
HE IS NOT CYNICAL, THE GUY HAS
BEEN IN WASHINGTON SO LONG YOU
WOULD THINK SOME OF US ARE HERE
TOO LONG AND YOU BECOME CYNICAL.
>> Sean: MAY BE YOU AT HOME
FEEL LIKE I DO, YOU PROBABLY
WANT TO PUKE.
TO DO THEY HAVE ANY SHAME AT
ALL?
LET’S TRAVEL BACK IN TIME FOUR
YEARS AGO TODAY.
LET’S LISTEN TO HOW TO BE MEDIA
MOB TREATED PRESIDENT TRUMP
DURING HIS INAUGURATION.
SLIGHT DIFFERENCE, YOU MIGHT
NOTICE.
TO TAKE A LOOK.
>> 2009 INAUGURATION OF NOW
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA ON LEFT
AND TRUMP’S INAUGURATION ON THE
RIGHT WITH FAR FEWER SPECTATORS.
>> HE SAID TODAY AMERICA FIRST,
IT WAS NOT JUST RACIAL
BACKGROUND TO IT.
>> THERE WERE SOME POCKET
PROTESTS, SOME CLASHES WITH
POLICE.
MORE THAN 200 PEOPLE WERE
ARRESTED.
THE CROWDS OF THE INAUGURATION
APPEARED TO BE SMALLER THAN THEY
WERE FOUR YEARS AGO.
>> AMERICAN CARNAGE.
THE PRESIDENTIAL INAUGURAL
ADDRESS THING.
BANG YOUR HEAD.
A LOT OF AMERICANS PROVERBIALLY
DID THAT TODAY.
>> HE BASICALLY TOOK THE HIDE
OFF OF EVERYBODY SITTING ON THAT
PLATFORM.
WE WILL BE UNPACKING THAT
SPEECH -- IT WILL TAKE US THE
REST OF THE DAY TO GET AROUND TO
THIS.
I’M NOT SURE I HAD ANY
INAUGURATION SPEECH QUITE LIKE
THIS.
>> Sean: WHAT DID THAT MEAN
ANYWAY?
I DON’T KNOW.
EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR FOUR PLUS
YEARS, THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE
HEARD AND WITNESS FROM THE MOB
AND MEDIA.
I DON’T THINK THEY KNOW WHAT
THEY DO.
IF THEY WERE NASTY, ABUSIVELY
CORRUPT, AND BIASED.
UNRELENTING, NATURALLY THE
VITRIOL CONTINUES TO THIS DAY.
THEY ARE ENTERING THEIR JOYOUS
PRAISE OF ALL THINGS JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS.
THE MOB AND MEDIA FOUND TIME FOR
THEIR FAVORITE OBSESSION, NEVER
STOP HATING DONALD TRUMP EVER.
APPARENTLY TRUMP LIVES IN THEIR
HEADS 24/7.
IT TAKE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AND TAKE
HIS TIME THE WHITE HOUSE MUCH
LIKE HE DID IN IT, DEFIANT,
AVOIDING RESPONSIBILITY, IT --
>> THE DISGRACED 45TH PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND FIRST
LADY MELANIA TRUMP.
>> HE LOOKS SMALL.
HE LOOKS LIKE A SMALL MAN.
>> A PRESIDENT WHO FELT NEITHER
CONNECTED TO THAT TRADITION NOR,
AT MANY TIMES, TO A CONSTITUTION
THAT HE BELIEVED IT DID NOT
APPLY TO HIM.
>> IT’S A LITTLE PLED PATHETIC.
>> HE’S LEAVING TOWN LIKE A
AUTOCRAT OUSTED FROM POWER,
HEADING OFF INTO EXILE.
>> DONALD TRUMP WAS TRUE TO
HIMSELF, NOT FAKE, NOT PHONY,
AND HE WAS BEING HONEST.
IT YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK GO HAVE YOUR DAY, I
DON’T NEED TO BE HERE.
IF YOU LISTEN CLOSELY YOU MIGHT
BE ONTO SOMETHING.
HE TALKED ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN EXILE.
OKAY, JIM, WHATEVER YOU WISH.
A FAKE NEWS JIM ACOSTA, HERE’S
THE THING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE GET TO
DECIDE WHO LIVES AT
1600 PENNSYLVANIA AVENUE, AND
FOUR YEARS THEY COULD VERY
EASILY DECIDE TO BRING THE
PRESIDENT BACK FOR SECOND TERM.
YOUR HATE WILL CONTINUE,
ASSUMING SENATE REPUBLICANS ARE
NOT STUPID AND FRACTURE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY COMPLETELY AND
FORCE AMERICA FIRST
CONSERVATIVES INTO SPLITTING OFF
INTO ANOTHER PARTY WHICH WOULD
BE A DISASTER WHICH I DON’T
THINK WOULD HAPPEN.
HE’S ONTO SOMETHING HERE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN EXILE.
FINE, WE WILL FOLLOW JIM’S LEAD.
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS MOVING
FORWARD, HERE’S A PROMISE TO
YOU.
WE WILL ALWAYS BE INDEPENDENT,
FIERCELY INDEPENDENT.
WE WILL DO OUR BEST TO BRING YOU
THE TRUTH WHEN THE MOB WILL NOT
DO THAT.
WE ARE NOT THEM, WE WILL NEVER
BE THEM.
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS, WE
WILL CONTINUE TO VET JOE BIDEN.
WE WILL STOP HIS RADICAL
SOCIALIST AGENDA AND IN ANYWHERE
WE CAN.
MUST NOT FORGET ABOUT OUR
ONGOING HANNITY INVESTIGATION
INTO THE CORRUPT BIDEN FOREIGN
FAMILY BUSINESS.
WE ARE TOLD, AND I’VE BEEN TOLD,
I’VE BEEN BRIEFED BY PEOPLE THAT
KNOW THAT THE CONTENTS OF HUNTER
BIDEN’S LAPTOP ARE BEYOND
DISTURBING.
TOOK TOMORROW, WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE RIGHT HERE ON THIS SHOW A
MUST-SEE INTERVIEW WITH THE
OWNER OF THAT COMPUTER REPAIR
SHOP.
HE’S THE ONE THAT COPIED THE
HARD DRIVE ON HUNTER’S LAPTOP
AND HANDED IT OVER TO FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES THAT SAT ON IT FOR A
LONG TIME.
THAT’S THE ONE THAT BIG TECH